I think it is time we informed the
Senate that our ability to use
what where did that come from and even
if it's true why would you tell the
obviously corrupt Senate also this movie
uses the word Senate senator and vote
more than it uses the word force only
the Dark Lord of the Sith no safar
weakness
thankfully he's not also the Supreme
Chancellor I mean she could you imagine
no you got that right I saw my mother
thank God a vision came to Anakin to go
save his mother I just wish it could
have happened about 30 minutes ago I'm
sorry I don't have a choice you're right
you have no choice between ignoring your
dream mom's drama and continuing to
honor your non dream pledge to hide and
protect Padme
fate is forcing your hand as it often
does through vague dreams Oh what the
hell is going on how do we get here
obi-wan fistfights with this dude
instead of force choking him or force
pushing him or any of the other non
hand-to-hand force attacks ah yes of
course I remembered to bring my
throwable homing beacon that instantly
sticks to anything I throw it towards
also the world of Star Wars is one in
which a homing beacon like this can just
casually be tossed on your ship without
side ship sensors picking it up
whatsoever shouldn't rain be hitting the
lightsaber and producing little puffs of
smoke do you know where they are now
it's amazing even with all the Jedi
training and peacekeeping he's done over
ten years there was at one time he was
allowed to fly over to Tatooine and
visit his mom you must have put a homing
device on our home they do realize
they're being tracked but only after
they arrived at their destination income
convenient this is a clear case where
the challenge is way too high for anyone
to survive it therefore you just sit the
théâtre wondering why obi-wan isn't dead
I know that ladies and gentlemen tell me
why is it in Star Wars when the bad guy
ships fire the good guy ships the lasers
go all around the ship instead of at
least one blast hitting it once again
something easily catches up to another
something that can't close any further
distance when it's 50 feet away we won't
be seeing him again overly cocky Jango
Fett is overly cocky hey I remember that
scene I just noticed something there's
really no reason artoo couldn't have
come on this mission all he's doing
right now is following Padme Anakin
around I'm pretty sure r4 is the bread
r2 you look for in toy stores at this
point stay with the ship r2 why did you
even let him out I am c-3po through
Watteau sold me to some other person and
she decided to take the incomplete c-3po
with her and someone decided to finish
the job Owen laws this is my girlfriend
Beru let me get this straight the powers
that be decided that Luke would someday
come to live here even though Anakin met
Owen and Beru
he didn't think
that would be a huge risk what if Vader
decided to come back to the old
homestead for whatever reason not that
I'm complaining but Padme decided to
wear the super hot AB baring outfit to
go meet Annie's mom the editing is
confusing
we were logically following Anakin as he
seeks bloody revenge against the Tusken
Raiders who killed his mom and this
scene makes us think we're still
following him but no we're suddenly on
an entirely different planet following
obi-wan we must persuade the Commerce
guild and the corporate alliance to sign
the treaty just once I'd like to see
somebody hiding in a corner somewhere
and the bad guys aren't talking about
the most important essence of their plan
in earshot just once I'd like to hear
they had bagels for breakfast or
something
furthermore the guy he was following
Jango Fett isn't even in this meeting
with Count Dooku so what kind of luck is
that he just decided to walk around and
find a secret opening in the mountains
and stumble on the plot of the movie
Count Dooku walks right past a Jedi here
and does not sense him stay with me mom
in the grand tradition of all dining
Star Wars characters Shmi held on long
enough for one final meeting before
passing away also Anakin watches his
mother die because something something
Darkseid motivation something something
this movie doesn't earn the Darkseid
transformation of Anakin he was a whiny
kid for most of this movie and now he
massacres a bunch of Tuscans had someone
been here to stop him and that need for
revenge festered in his heart the next
time would be a good time for a massacre
most of everything we know about Anakin
was talked about not shown and this
comes off as a rush Hey suffering yeah
that apparently your ability to use the
Force isn't good anymore so what can you
trust yeah hmm I don't feel any of that
but maybe I should act like I do what's
the bigger sin here bad guy bug things
stumbling upon obi-wan or obi-wan
parking his ship out in the goddamn open
like this Anakin takes his dead rotting
mother into the house because Jedi
reasons and also disease why'd she have
to die she probably didn't but he left
her alone here as a slave on this planet
to pursue your own Jedi goals what did
you think was gonna happen to her
happily ever after I will be the most
powerful Jedi ever this is pretty much
par for the course as to why we hated
this performance we kind of want Anakin
to start being a colder person
definitely a lot less whiny at this
point mork Darth Vader II instead our
brains keep referring to their shut up
section I killed them all
don't use the pronoun game Annie using
the pronoun game leads to the dark side
and she still had sex with him after
this for some reason and not just the
men but the women and the children too
Anakin can somehow tell Tuscan women and
children from the men I'm not even mad
at that's amazing
I'm a Jedi I know I'm better than this
and this is the only time we see Anakin
struggle with the good and bad of his
feelings everything else has been dark
side and one a screw Padme I miss you so
much
Lukas asked him to deliver this line as
though his dick got cut off halfway
through but he also knew an enchanted
fairy would eventually grow his dick
back so he's not super concerned about
it but he wants to see him like he is
carrying a message from an obi-wan
Kenobi and Master Agee does that name
mean anything to you
owner if he means old Ben I have tracked
the Bounty Hunter Jango Fett to the
Droid foundries on Geonosis despite the
fact that Jango completely disappeared
from the action I managed to stumble
upon a completely new part of the plot
that is important for all the good guys
to know hologram action sequence he's
like my father but you heard Master
Windu he gave me strict orders to stay
here and obi-wan gave you strict orders
to stay on the boot and we saw how that
worked like a focus c-3po suddenly on
this mission
if only senator Amidala we're here
entire sequence of events leads to Jar
Jar making an important decision in the
Senate to give Palpatine more power also
was this part of Palpatine's plan did he
know that Padme would appoint the
dumbest character alive to be her
replacement when hit the fan how awesome
would this be if Dooku had been in the
first movie and the first movie wasn't
the first movie
how many awesome backstories that we
left to imagine while the story leaves
us wanting the dark side of the force
has clouded their vision my friend again
how perfect time to explain this bullsh
and immediately goes on to the next
subject wait this is an exhaust vent
they landed it right do exhaust vents
usually have perfect landing platforms
for ships what are you going now r2
decides to go against orders and leave
the ship anyway something he must only
be doing to piss off c-3po at this point
because at no time is r2 shown a
tendency to go against orders since the
new trilogy began conveyor belt of
dangerous industry cliche also this is
the most video-gaming assed movie scene
ever included the movie just to sell a
videogame
I guess r2 knew that this would turn out
okay what a psychotic little bastard hey
there Star Wars fan FYI r2d2 comply cute
I wonder what happened to poor little r2
he's always getting himself into trouble
how do you know that you've only known
r2 for a couple hours and don't get me
he knew him from the first movie crap
either because Threepio was an
off-and-on incomplete robot the entire
time I'm so confused
maybe that explains why you aren't funny
anymore
movie is an asshole that is the very
definition of cheating and filmmaking
you fucker
this is equivalent to telling your
mother you have terminal cancer and then
once you start sobbing you trash talk
about how you pranked her and how stupid
she is give me a break
why would there be anything like this
sitting around in this random part of
the factory and once again our two
compatible I still can't figure out why
Django even needs to be here on one
planet he's the guy they used to make
clones on another planet they're making
army BOTS and he's here because obi-wan
needed to catch a break I thought that
we had decided not to fall in enough you
see why the romance should have taken
off a lot sooner
there's basically 40 minutes left in
this movie and they're still trying to
resolve this love you George Lucas
thinks people talk this way also Jedi
skip our heroes luck out and are taken
to an arena to be executed instead of
simply getting killed on the spot movie
unintentionally inspires John Carter I
might be scared of these things if they
didn't look like Tex Avery drawings put
into the weird science machine and
donated to the umbrella corporation I've
got a bad feeling about this character
breaks the fourth wall to talk to the
audience about the film itself
this creature basically didn't want to
kill Amidala just make her sexier
nobody seems particularly concerned that
one of the prisoners is free this thing
is terrible at thinking both also a
simple kick to the chest incapacitates
this heaping mound of psychosis hey
George while we're here humanizing Boba
Fett was one of the stupidest ideas you
had in these prequels and that's saying
something
aren't these animals weak-minded enough
so they can Jedi mind trick them or is
that just a human to human interaction
obi-wan pokes at the Beast instead of
just force throwing the spear into its
brain ow my vagina
you're impossibly odd-number I don't
think so how do these robots know to
start coming down the hallway
everyone in power is here no one gave an
order or pressed a button or anything
that would make a robot army start
coming down here dramatically and why
only four of them Star Wars finally
gives us a nerdgasm scene with dozens of
Jedi and lightsabers all at once and I'd
take a sin or two off if I hadn't had to
sit through two movies a mostly boring
bull to finally get this since you
enjoyed this in Phantom Menace so much
Lucas ups the ante with even more Jedi
versus copious amounts of CGI droids
smited the drone with the c-3po head
decide to march into battle doesn't his
mind work differently wouldn't he just
go lie down somewhere until all this was
over Jesus Christ skip
Django Unchained I'm terribly sorry
about basically these things don't even
need heads if they have no control with
them all I fuck beside myself I hate you
and I wish you would die first off this
is too many goddamn shots to block
second and maybe more importantly Padme
doesn't have a lightsaber
how does she live look Eagles return
create I was at Yoda I couldn't hear you
over the battle this ship and your
3-pack add a voice so if his dad's head
had fallen out of the helmet right here
would have been even more traumatized or
you know you think he would have laughed
a little cuz come on that's funny also
the birth of Bubba Fett might have been
cool if that asshole didn't get casually
tossed in a Sarlacc okay Sam you're
running you're running there's all sorts
of battle going on around you we'll fill
that in later the debts are is
apparently fully operational in like 20
years they must have had a million
contractors working 24/7 on that thing
cerebrum aside shoot him now
you you are not why are you even still
flying around then why didn't you tell
anyone that before we got to this point
you're gonna pay for all the Jedi that
you killed today Dooku saying things
electricity curiously a treat only
darkside force users hat what a fing
surprise is that the fiftieth limb got
off in this franchise he couldn't finish
them both off right now or at least
obi-wan if he knows where Anakin is
headed but besides NAT the dark side I
sense in you which I somehow can't sense
when I'm on Khorasan when Palpatine is
run and we've established we've lost
much of our force power but I can now
Yoda finally pulls out a lightsaber he
finally fights it took 10 hours of Star
Wars to finally see this a nun torn
because he's a bastard CGI creation why
does this guy need a cane again here was
a glorious chance to see three Jedi all
combining their Force power together and
stopping the ship from flying or as we
said before why can't Yoda just stop the
ship himself if size doesn't matter
this thing is smaller than Luke ship in
the swamp the force is powerful but it's
no match for an internal combustion
engine
everybody goddamn missus let's talk
about Palpatine's plan it required
Amidala to be taken off the planet so
she couldn't vote on the military
Creation Act then she had to make Jar
Jar Binks her replacement who was then
passively bullied to request a vote
granting unlimited power to Palpatine
then the Jedi have to stumble on a
poison dart that was only used because
another assassin failed a dart that only
a diner owner could verify then
Palpatine removed the planet from the
archives which required even more sleuth
work then when obi-wan went to the
Colonna planet the people there showed
in the entire plot no questions asked
which led him to Jang
Django had to curiously leave for
another planet where the droids were
being manufactured so that obi-wan could
relate that message back to the Republic
and only then could they get the ball
rolling without all that what did he
plan to do a gun the clone war has
did yo to just name this war or did the
Jedi have some prophecy that warned of a
clone war
I mean who gave him the authority to
name Wars do you yes do you dude I like
totally did away Lots
my goodness you've grown more beautiful
on me
you've grown up I'll try to grab too
fast but I am grown up I've changed so
much you haven't changed a bit
you're sure about it huh hey mother
scratch a scratch your arms off now it
isn't
you've grown up because your blows up
and your throws up and your groans up
over the first billion years the
universe continued to expand and cool as
matter gravitated into these massive
concentrations we call galaxies there
are filled endless fields where human
beings are no longer
born we are grown Hey for axiom your
home sweet home
these four by and large your very best
friend
stop all the clocks cut off the
telephone prevent the dog from barking
with a juicy born silence the pianos and
with muffled drum you sir truly are mr.
incredible you know I was right to
idolize you I I always knew you were
tough but tricking the probe by hiding
under the bones of another super oh man
I'm still get with these mother snakes
on this mother good boy
that's what we
haha